can you address a little bit of the
forever chemicals because I had read
that study about yoga pants we covered
it on the show that people were they did
all this testing on yoga pants and found
that a lot of these very popular brands
had these forever chemicals that can
potentially leech out into your body and
you're sweating in the gym this is I
mean think about a yoga pan it's very
very close contact with the body what
are these forever chemicals that
everyone's talking about now what do
they do to the body and if you can give
some inspiration to people that there
are alternatives if you can speak to
that a little bit that it's not hopeless
when you hear all this stuff and there
are companies that are working really
hard to provide goods and services that
are non-toxic for people or as non-toxic
as they can get mm-hmm before the class
of forever chemicals or some of the most
egregious chemicals out there
um and ubiquitous when it comes to
Forever chemicals those are
polyfluorinated chemicals they're called
pifas pfas and it's not just one
chemical it's it's many many chemicals
if you think of Teflon most of us have
seen a teflon cooking pan that non-stick
phenomenon is because of these
polyfluorinated chemicals there are
there's a membrane that is waterproof
it's hydrophobic so this membrane that
phenomenon was put into clothes for
quite a while so if you think about
outdoor clothes right rain jackets pants
that that Wick water and then that moved
into undergarments right there's a lot
of clothing right bras
um uh underwear that that are moisture
wicking and then that moved into the
yoga pants phenomenon which is for for
most people moisture wicking so anytime
you see waterproof
moisture wicking wrinkle free stain free
these things that are kind of too good
to be true you can almost guarantee that
this chemical has been used well why is
it a problem
for multiple reasons
if you think about the environmental
impact they tested some of the purest
Waters in the world furthest away from
everything and pifas are in there okay
so it has environmental impact it's
being circulated and recirculated in our
environment they've been reducing the
use of them and by they I mean uh Dupont
Dupont was the creators of this Teflon
and pifas and if you're ever on a side
note seeing the movie Dark Waters with
Mark Ruffalo this is this movie
highlights a small town in Ohio which
was Downstream from the factory that was
being poisoned by pifas first with their
cattle and then with human beings
developing cancer so when I say they
affect us they affect us thyroid breast
cancer all different types of cancer
respiratory disease you name it when it
comes to pifas the bigger problem is is
they stay in our body about 8 to 12
years they're called Forever chemicals
because they stay in the environment
forever but they stay in our environment
in our body for a very very a long time
so you mentioned going to the gym with
these yoga pants well when they did the
test on these yoga pants where were most
of the pifas found and it was actually
in the crotch area which is a big
problem right the study also showed that
certainly when uh there's when they're
sweating pifas are absorbed when it's
exposed to heat pifas are absorbed and
even there's some evidence that shows
that even if it's not exposed to heat or
not exposed to sweat and you're just
wearing them it's still absorbed also
found in sports bras where were most of
the beef was found around the nipple
right so imagine of course like you go
to yoga you don't want your nipple
showing through so it's protecting it
right that makes sense but imagine the
mom who is wearing a sports bar goes to
yoga goes back home uh uh and
breastfeeds your child for something
later in the day so these things we have
to start thinking about the people is
actually are one of the I would say BPA
uh pifas
are probably too I would mold is another
one in the home but BP and pifas are I
would say in the top five of uh most
damaging chemicals that we're being
exposed to why are why is this happening
is this just making goods and services
cheaper is that is it just because I
know that now and I want to remind
everyone again because I know that when
you hear this stuff for the first time
it can be very distressing and very
overwhelming
Dr giano if you know this I have a two
and a half year old when I built the my
baby registry I went for all non-toxic
stuff everyone thought I was insane they
thought I was completely insane
everything from his mattress to his
furniture to paint interestingly when we
start when I started in this company and
I did the podcast there was an incident
with paint and I was like I'm not going
in the building right now we need I have
an air purifier in my room I'm very
conscious of this stuff and people
oftentimes will think I'm crazy and what
they'll say is oh you have a liver you
have a liver what do you say to people
who hear this stuff one feel overwhelmed
so we want to have them feel positive
walking away from this that there are
companies again every single thing in my
home my furniture I do everything I can
my cleaning products all of these
companies exist that will offer
non-toxic options but what do you say to
people who are Skeptics and immediately
the second you start talking you say
well you have a liver to detox don't
worry about all this stuff
I mean yeah of course we have a liver to
detox and and we have kidneys and we
have skin and we poop right and we sweat
we have mechanisms but that doesn't mean
that they're not overwhelmed and
certainly if you're suffering with
disease you can almost guarantee that
you're a monkeys or routes of
detoxification are overwhelmed if if if
someone is telling me and they're in the
best health and they go actually go by
the philosophy that I have a liver so
I'm fine then I listen but if that
person has any mental emotional or
physical disruption and they say I have
a liver well then it might be a problem
right our liver can detoxify uh or or
break down metabolize so much our
kidneys can do so much our skin we poop
we sweat but that doesn't mean that the
cup isn't filling or filled up for so
many people and a major driver of
filling up this cup and when it
overflows disease manifests a major
driver is toxic load the size of that
cup is determined by you genetically and
also how stressed you are but that cup
regardless for anyone is filling up
right by living in this world it's
filling up
but it would behoove us then to go okay
how can I make the small changes in my
home it doesn't have to be in the first
month it could be three years it could
be a four-year plan but how can you
start slowly implementing the things
that we really need to look for to do
better by the air that we're breathing
what we're putting in our mouth and what
we're putting in our skin if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]